serena
oh
oh jesus christ
just watched scott screen that was the
first
that was oh hi welcome to three
da mo for top name i was
well overall of course and i was
just saying my name is lauren hi
lauren hello so nice i'm finally i'm
scott aka been so nice to meet
you oh wow hi cool hi big
fan
really of what the movie big fan
oh okay great we've had a big
fan of yossi guys i listened to
you guys on three of them every
week
while recording it with you
you know what that's really true i
listen twice a week
once back after we do it
wow record twice in one day jesus
christ wow
nothing got enjoy your life okay bye
wow you were talking to have a
great time
i just didn't s l schuette pester
now yes yes an and l saturday
night handler it's saturday night and life
um welcome to the show for another
week it's this is of course the
show where we i don't like you
dragging this comedy bang bang lingo into
a show fucked up dude this is
not that show this shows so we
just freaking talk we generally get just
launching without express we shoot
the es um speaking of s and
l i am listening to shit and
what
saturday and live oh i'm listening to
laraine newman's audiobook and it's really good
oh cool oh i didn't know she
had a book yeah it's called me
you live in interesting times and it's
very chinese acres is that said ah
yeah hers yeah yeah oh i don't
know that well now you do it's
a curse word it's it's a curse
like thinner i didn't think may live
in interesting times was the equivalent of
fuck and you may live energy types
all one word um
forward slash
well anyway it's really good okay um
who reads it she does watts of
course she does and she does so
many voices and it makes it really
great i think it's i like when
does she do baluch
um well she she does like so
she does talk about a lot of
sketches and she um you know sort
of not doesn't digitally do impressions of
the people doing the sketches but she
kind of you know loosely well in
some of those moments but she in
her stories even just what where she's
quoting herself as a kid she does
voices and it really enhances and i
like when people
i like audiobooks when enhance well because
i listened to audiobooks every once in
awhile and it's always better when the
person doing it is like a performer
and not just a rino let me
ask you this loren lapidus when you
listen to the audiobooks because i'm not
an audiobook guy because i listened to
i listen to a lot of podcasts
and i i listen to those when
i'm doing other things or driving or
whatever i my fear is if i'm
listening to an audio book i will
i will lose the thread of what
wind up the sacramento because it's not
i don't want to go there even
though it's our state capital and i
respect this keep driving and driving i
just i
mike long a map where the dragons
are
um so i is is it it
feel like you're driving listen to an
audio book um are you able to
follow along do you ever find yourself
like spacing out i've had moments where
i missed something with audiobooks and i'll
just rewind it but like for the
most part i like it because i
listen to a lot of podcasts too
and i will always reach stages
well no i do though okay okay
and well there always is a point
where i've listened to all of my
new podcasts and i'm like oh i
don't have anything listen to and i
really want something and then i'll remember
my audiobook section and then i'll put
that on and then and then i
can spend a whole day with someone
like with lorraine i was like listening
to her for like four hours one
day and it was like the it
felt it felt
i like it also feels like productive
in a way well because technically it's
a book it's a book
so you can say you read the
book you ever do that but like
i don't i don't say that i
say i got the audiobook say also
that casey wilson's audio book and i
really liked hearing her read it and
i also think the when you tell
the author i got the audiobook it's
like makes that worth their time because
you know it's like a whole thing
they had to do exactly so you
feel sorry for these people
i wonder what relevancy i liked your
book i would say i like your
audio book because right performed it i
wonder what takes longer writing the book
or performing the audiobook
i assume most books are written in
the amount of time takes reader hey
no no orange dying there's no oh
no for a waterway yeah so wrong
pipe
what is the wrong type what's the
like what a pipe in the wrong
pipe along the right the right pipe
is tummy pipe the wrong pipe stereotype
is yeah really put them next to
each other i know flow get me
my air pipe is my tummy pipe
do you think that when you swallow
water and it goes into your lungs
by accident just days there and gets
i'll stay
magnet and there's flies yes okay thank
you for answering my question so you
guys had a romantic getaway to talk
about huh
ah well first lorna you ever gonna
ride you ever going to write a
book about babies yeah whatever yeah i
want to and i babysit this has
been maybe a coach joined or formed
yeah it's been coming up mr resolved
i just um need to really think
about what i would want
wait sorry but did they just join
a club and not tell mystery what
scope is not a mystery book it's
what i do what are they hanging
out just babysitting like stories about bases
there's there's trials and tribulations of being
a babysitter sure i don't know to
be my profession but but but but
paul it's also friendships up above it's
family it's everything
because okay have you watched the babysitters
club a tv show and you should
say no of course i've watched every
single think if we had was due
we would know what it was about
but this show is so cute and
it's so well made and read that
i've heard it's cry i passed through
while cool up with i came through
while coop was watching joe oh god
oh
whoa babysitter it's truly the cutest show
and by the way i'll just vote
um
i'll take this opportunity to say that
my patreon i covered every episode of
the babysitters club okay years that smell
someone out there might and that may
oh what have we demeaned your other
dumb podcast that you do you did
earlier in the show no shit
so romantic weekend thoughts concerns
well we kissed
and i thought about it i'm concerned
we went to santa barbara and we
had a lovely time it was it
was scott and cool up in myself
and janie and um we were in
a house together um and the ideal
re true story the idea was that
we were going to get do you
know work on our various projects and
things like that at a leisurely pace
as we were
out of town and in a nice
serene spot and it was really very
enjoyable there was a pool there were
like harley yeah oh no we brought
those they didn't turn your dogs yeah
they didn't come with the house i
was wondering why they were very attached
to you guys like and we ordered
them around and as i meant wow
they have a row
real affinity for animals i guess because
these dogs love them we went to
restaurants if yeah leave it every night
every night yes
two more nights cool sorry laura darling
law was requester hula this is this
restaurant roundup oh does this count just
going to them it's it's restaurant recap
oh wrestle recap oh the masha we've
all been waiting for speaking of reality
recap yeah chris harrison is out as
he's out especially
oh that's right anyway back to us
you want to take us play would
you take his place if they offered
it to that would be such a
weird turn i mean i am seeing
that all these comedians are going to
be stepping in during the bachelor in
paradise they're they're just doing it for
like a week at a time because
they're like movie stars who don't want
to downgrade oh i know and i
hear up there
a former babysitter turns current movie star
and so wouldn't be a downgrade your
say
for me to suddenly be on love
island with these people and like flirting
with wells the bartender i think i'm
ok okay wait um wait that said
if you see me on there it's
because it was a really fun opportunity
ok
bachelor in paradise is what happens there
that's where the sex can happen because
anybody can hook up it's obviously lying
on the show or some foreigner and
then thirty of another it's okay it's
party time it's a bunch of ah
it's a bunch of former contestants yeah
and sometimes not for contestants they just
throw random
in horny soils madonna bouche and then
they become like favorites because they're on
tv and people want to see him
the next season and stuff yeah wanna
do yeah then why are they bothering
i don't know anyway so that bother
anyone the yeah they're not bothering leave
him alone so the point of that
show is joe
just who did you have sex with
last night so basically you have to
like be in a couple to stay
on the island it's like a whole
thing taking it really seriously at the
end where they're like if you're not
going to stay in a couple just
leave now and i'm always like who
would leave now like you get one
more episode out of this and then
you also get to stay is pretty
hotel on the beach and whatever it
is so why
and so this is the this is
the worst part of all reality tv
is they all have to sleep in
bunk beds that's just so gross why
are people having sex in bunk beds
yeah and believe it
not top bunk
no would you would climb up there
to have sex and while i've heard
but paul if you're both tops one
of you has to do the top
button and anyone like drew if you
want like tom oh yeah of course
i do well i mean i'm a
power bottom but sheer power button bunk
bug
it's what i know from solar yeah
wasn't it
forgot about bunk don't forget about ever
i still have a bunk ah whiskey
glass
weird yeah it's sort of incentive to
hurt the other days like mine broke
years ago
so you guys went to restaurants every
night and yes did you had you
been going to think about you ever
that's fine that's fine don't worry sweetie
lauren i thought about you every day
um okay that's also weird
every minute of it for you both
should have thought of me just a
little that would have been of i
thought of you constantly
um we were all going out at
all when you before you went to
santa barbara i went to one in
palm springs but i don't i haven't
been doing la restaurant since yeah i'd
since i've been to one la restaurant
and it was a great experience i
think i talked about it on this
program you did and but to go
out every night it was weird how
um normal
all it seemed like that's not something
i do oh god yeah that's right
everything even even traveling i don't necessarily
go to a restaurant every single night
but um it was fun it was
a lot of fun we had a
lot of good food and we had
fun conversation and lots of pictures i
mean we were going crazy like shutterbug
god and we we got blank
it's at one restaurant i didn't get
one it was so cool you see
we were sitting with patio and it
was so cold that the waiter offered
us blankets yeah i was too damaged
to bold i was too full of
myself to to accept one but my
wife didn't i was jealous i hated
her and resented her for it yeah
yeah this
what i want and i thought of
you
ah and we we we didn't go
to one without paul wow what were
you doing that was a breakfast place
i'm not good at going out to
breakfast you are slightly woke up i
woke up late starting you're like oh
awesome you want to hoard it and
scavenge it you don't want to hurt
it i wanna scavenge it paul from
trying i felt like oh
from going on tour i feel like
i would say that you sleep in
slash don't want to go out in
the morning i don't want to go
out in the morning i like to
have breakfast in my room if there's
get it delivered with the little tab
on your door that says right give
me this set seven the night before
i love it yeah um i was
not getting
and this and this might have happened
on tour as well i'm i was
not getting great sleep um for some
reason i think it was a temperature
thing because i think it was a
temperature thing yeah it was going too
hot it was a little too hot
we were also sleeping in a smaller
bed than we usually do and i
think okay well in bunk beds were
a mug beds and he rises and
janie puts out
a lot of heat and so the
heat was coming up in waves to
my top bunk facing nowhere in one
you are in the bottom she was
in the top and then across the
way cool up and scott were also
on top and bottom yes with the
house was one room it was an
air bnb but we were only allowed
to be in one room
and the hosts were there the whole
time they were very loud they were
playing their music at all hours i
put down masking tape across the center
of the room and wasn't allowed to
cross wow fight yeah
anyway and so so yeah so i
that want that one day i slept
i i kept falling i kept waking
up and falling sleep and it was
miserable and then i finally woke up
at ten and i was like i
can't keep these guys from going to
breakfast i said go on with our
way went and it was the reason
i wanted to go was to go
to that place because anytime i go
to santa bar
ibra we go to the shop kitchen
and get the yolo the biscuits and
gravy with chicken and sausage gravy and
i saw pictures that looked delicious i
can't blame you yeah it was good
and ah we ah i'm trying to
think of anything else we did that
was it there's a pool there was
a pool we went to the beach
to visit
our own that's all john ryan to
be oh yeah you guys send to
picture and i was like who's everyone
in the picture except tojo jonah nor
that was nora's family her parents and
her brother and sister-in-law and and of
course glory little gloria happy allows hue
and ors ma was wearing a great
t-shirt t-shirts
said we didn't notice it until we
were leaving her t-shirt said i simply
love tony shalhoub
oh my god i need that for
mike's mom she really does he wow
makes mom now doesn't love tony sean
sweeney um
and i also noticed that her dad
had an adult swim sweatshirt on he
worked for adult swim for long that's
right yeah wow east ghost you did
their promos and cool lauren you may
have met them briefly backstage in atlanta
when we were on tour there oh
okay my family was all there too
so i don't i think i was
destroyed were they there
again i have a lot of family
in atlanta oh spy range i have
zero but but but but but but
that's so cool that he wrote first
on space ghost yeah like i was
when because i think it's on hbo
max now or something i just threw
on a random episode and he's in
it that's sweet
um i used to like that show
um you in the between two ferns
movie got cut out oh well then
i didn't see him i win
win again in your movie um the
janie commiserated on the beach
wow although bitch yeah it was cheney's
role she was ex roommate
oh and the family marie knows she
and rory scovel were his roommates um
they weren't married he's on the floor
from this film i know there's a
there's probably two and a half hours
that we oh my god we should
have a full release of just the
ah family and home life a vague
daily account full really sorry
the andy daly account e-zine forty five
minute take oh my god and it
was just like one take and really
funny and it was in for a
while but it was confusing as forty
five minutes long yeah yeah
doesn't want to say cut
um look janie also very upset that
she could not get a hold of
the footage that netflix will not let
anyone have that footage yeah it's all
software you can't go onto real what
are you gonna do not footage yeah
yeah yeah well i feel like that
happens with anything where you it doesn't
end up airing but you can't get
it no one to let it out
out sometimes i've had that happen sometimes
where it's like a thing that didn't
go but that they owe like a
pilot or something yeah yeah i would
love to see slash not at all
um some of the pilots i was
meant didn't get picked out you might
never go back to watch them yeah
what were i'm trying to think because
i know i feel like there was
one that you were in that i
knew
saw it no no no i never
saw anything i haven't watched the stuff
you are it yeah i know it's
really hurtful
kidding i don't care i saw i
saw a pilot of mine recently when
i was you know digitizing all that
stuff it was a pilot that was
like a pre modern family type show
where it was a reality show about
a family um just one family not
like the extended family and two of
the writers went on to write for
modern family the the two guys that
created a went under right from our
family but i was essentially the ty
burrell role and i looking back at
it this guy is a fucking creep
you played yes he's like you didn't
realize it at the time at the
time at the time it was very
much like these the
sort of office antihero it was comedy
you know kind of cringe comedy yeah
and so he says things that are
inappropriate or whatever but you're still supposed
to care about the guy it was
very weird like he says vaguely racist
things sometimes and um ah like very
misogynistic and like he's a real creep
with the there's this birthday party
for there's like a barbeque and he's
like ogling these women it's fucking it
was so weird it was so weird
and gross that is weird
but at the time were like this
guy's cool i didn't think he was
cool necessarily but i embraced i embraced
i want to be like this guy
but scott you're pleased this is this
gets out there yeah i'm finished oh
no i'm sorry
oh well that's okay i have no
pilots that i ever did nah no
what about that next pilot were you
in that at all oh i made
pilots it was your next ah cameo
hitchcock god i don't remember i don't
think so but i can't remember i
directed a video for it but i
i do
i think that made the difference like
maybe if you'd been in it it
would have got picked up maybe yeah
i don't know everyone was saying because
i knew everyone who watched it was
like who made this i can't see
him yeah why is he behind the
casey invisible
um yeah now now um yeah no
um yeah no yeah yeah no yeah
no no no no yeah me too
i choose to believe you yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah thanks
da da do do do do do
do you get your romantic yes i
do back to your romantic getaway um
did you your jealousy is palpable but
i know it i know i'm pissed
did you feel rejuvenated afterwards like it
was like a vacation i did i
did and then i got back here
and and all fucking came crash
oh nah dude oh i all the
work i've been ignoring suddenly i'm back
to it oh no no no it
was good though at the time he
was it was productive in a way
ah dr yeah yeah it was like
i wish the duck deals i got
stuff done and i felt i did
feel rejuvenate anyone
i came back i was also very
happy to be back in my own
bed ah yeah and yeah it's like
the yesterday was what we got back
sunday night and then yesterday was an
extremely long day for me and i
think that about twenty trips i think
yeah like all twenty four and i
think that trip really helped because it
was i was going for
from thing to thing to thing all
day i got up early to go
to the gym and then my day
began and then it ended at like
what it was after our show lauren
so sick yeah that's why i was
like going all day from ah ten
thirty to six thirty um and then
i was and then i was done
by the way did you
call me during the show was that
show yeah okay so i see lauren
calling me in my immediate thought is
oh no something wrong oh my guy
and i saw i'm sorry i picked
up i would never have picked up
if i'd realised he was show time
and i was concerned i was like
hello like like worried yeah oh that's
nice and ah and then of course
you're just playing pranks on and then
i said i like to make a
collect call and then i couldn't stop
laughing and then hung up
i didn't realize he was calling you
scott she never said understand that until
after i was i was kind of
pranking paul at the same time oh
so sorry i heard you laugh scott
and i thought this guy's great whoever
this works is this guy gets it
yeah yeah you were like i'm so
that was so nice that he laughed
and then i was like that was
scott
and then you were like oh boy
god you hope school i was i
was really shocked we'd we were talking
about one hundred collective it was still
a thing yeah and so i tried
to call cool i tried to call
one hundred collect to call paul just
ask dan i'm also anyway
i'm ordeal i was like oh my
god well so then i um i
got through and and i then i
thought oh i should be calling scott
it's way funnier for that reveal instead
of hearing this clutch person so then
i called you this game but then
i called collette again to see if
it actually worked and it was so
weird because
i called when i called paul collect
it showed my name on his phone
which i thought was like we ah
and then we found out that it
was sixteen dollars for a collect call
what here's what's what's also very strange
as my phone instinctively sent that called
a voicemail like i just i held
up the phone to show lauren and
and then i it was like two
rings and then it went to smell
like somehow my phone knew this is
bullshit yeah yeah it was only weird
don't pick up for sixteen to wait
so someone got charged sixteen dollars no
it was if he had answered it
would have been like sixteen dollars for
thirty minutes or so yeah over thirty
minutes but i still think that's a
lot yeah well i mean no
one's calling anyone for thirty minutes it's
like it's a two minute call you
don't hear i'm at the corner of
this and this come pick me up
but it's still gonna be like then
a couple of bucks is going to
be global but we should we should
yank it out there for free if
that you're thinking he's summoned in to
competitive movie cars um
oh derek i know you mean the
larry the cable guy
hi hi i'm larry the cable car
guy in san francisco and already shipping
to my cable car what did the
cable car doesn't count as a car
oversight i think
um that's really funny you want wanna
really funny anyway
what i want to talk now is
the thing you want to make a
new collect call number sco who cares
what about what you want good point
who knows though is what i was
going to talk about but i will
talk about something else if you want
okay lawrence topics here we go we
had a very successful laurence topics a
few episodes ago yeah really successful it
was one of the most successful uh
um i have i guess two topics
oh okay one is that i'm they
one is that um well speaking of
little getaways make an i took a
little two-night hey baby little ways where
did you what you do work we
got we just got an air bnb
um in la quito randomly it was
just near palm springs budge found a
cute house with a pool
and we didn't um go anywhere so
it didn't matter that it because ah
you know covert and whatnot um but
it was really great to go to
a lord of the rings of there
i did try to do that on
our anniversary and it was a huge
yes sake i remember oh no my
computer's doing that thing what thing
where it's making oh i no it's
a lawnmower nirmala that is my
aw man there's a lawn mower outside
my house to another one that's i
know that's what it was i thought
it was my computer is the law
computing things why did you get it
it was confused you know how my
computer was making that fan noise i
think the way it was coming through
is going the other way hey god
i was trying to really explain it
um but i can't wave we didn't
do anything we just like hung
out to swim in the pool and
i just kept going this is this
is so fun when i can make
it going i know stuff saying that
are you worried
were you worried being in the pool
that you would suddenly have a water
birth
maybe you would just be like finally
i'm out of here nobody was really
weird getting out of the pool because
suddenly i was like really heavy like
when i would climb up the stairs
i'd like to do like it was
like crazy like all the water was
like my stomach when it was like
when i was in the water i
was like felt fine and then when
i got out of it it was
like i could feel the weight of
it again more sponge bathe
wingsuit right
spongebob yeah i get squeezed out after
um but anyway yeah we tried to
go to this one um last october
and it was it was october thirty
first or so no it was our
anniversary um and nicole had sent me
nicole byer had sent me this error
a and b listing that was like
a hobbit hole and because we were
doing the lord of the rings on
our podcast the time right and so
i kind of blindly was like let's
go there and it was such a
disaster i mean have i not talked
about this i feel like we talked
about it in life but i don't
know you know it's truly tear
terrifying like we pulled up and it
was like so creepily arizona so what
it was was it was a it
was a what do you call it
shipping container made into an air bnb
that was oh shit it was like
a had a whole it looked like
it was built into a hill on
the pressures right and so it looked
cool and then in person it was
odd
easily the creepiest and grossest thing i've
ever seen the guy we left like
instantly um still we we got there
and we walked inside though we went
into it will we we hemmed and
hawed about it we tried and we
tried out every chair ground door and
every yeah yeah it had this big
round glass door and it literally cool
hopefully i know what little it looked
it looks really private the way it
was photographed glass doors in the they
sure didn't realize you needed it to
be glasser because it was so fucking
dark in this world thing so why
weren't they in the hobbit movies then
if you need a glass door for
it to be like well i mean
in in the way it is in
the habit they're okay with it being
dark and the way it is i
i would like to have suddenly like
dark i don't know dark but it
was we got there and it was
like we pulled in we were like
this can't be it like we we
first liked joe passing a few times
because it was behind a house and
then we finally go okay i think
this is it we pull in and
there's like loser there's like a guy
like with his truck like doing something
at the
front house and it seemed likely a
guy with his truck doing something at
the front house yeah it's it just
seemed really weird and and then we
we go okay she's lawyered i think
we've struck doing something at the what
do you mean with his truck doing
something okay so there was like a
creepy truck parked in front of the
main house great truck you didn't mention
that part and the house itself look
kt like grow so yeah it looked
like it wasn't taking care of very
well was grumpy about the truck was
it like the the drag from the
clippers it was a bit junky and
then this guy came out and he
looked knee looked like someone i want
to talk to okay thank a caretaker
or two's like you know oh go
down he was a young guy who
looked like
he was like a young white guy
who had like a couple in poor
you mentioned that he's missing will give
you a to give you an image
and so we talking to front and
yeah some some some key essential front
teeth were gone so and he wants
you one you're gonna want to open
your cans
right so he he was weird and
then we go down we realised we
were you're weird to walk down the
house hey you're weird tickets
elevate house and there was this chicken
coop that was completely falling down chicken
coop and it looked to so gross
it was like i don't and there
were some chickens around it and it
said mom like scrawled into it it
was it looked scary foot the funk
and we were like do we turn
back now like it was like we
couldn't we left our bags in the
car were like let's just go
check this out surely this will be
fine yeah everything around to get terrifying
but this will be a ok and
it also was like short walk to
the beach not true at all it
was like a full drive and then
when you got there like a million
cars you couldn't get so it's like
the whole idea of the relaxing trip
was like none of it was gonna
happen yeah and at this point we'd
already know
not been anywhere for you know a
year so it was like this was
supposed to be like a nice thing
but yeah we get there and then
we we find the place and we're
like ooh it feels kind of like
sketchy and weird and i was like
it was just like dirty feeling inside
and like the uli idea of like
i mean dvd of airbnb be like
beds is like such
why because yes you need to know
that it's been like really clean it's
not like a hotel where it feels
like there's some more accountability slash they
could always work place it very quickly
for yeah there's a mechanism in place
there like with this i was like
i don't want to get on this
bed like i feel like really like
ooh about the bed and the dovey
cupboard it was like
yeah and then the bathrooms where and
then i was thinking about how i
had just learned about how some people
um have been filmed at the airbnbs
and i was like there's definitely a
camera in here he was just like
it was just like gross and then
we're like alright let's try to sit
outside and see if it's nice like
if we sit outside because they were
like some lawn chairs and stuff and
we can't really win to every room
tried every well there's
one room it was a shipping container
and then outside of that was um
like a little patio area with some
like you know furniture and we and
there were they were like metal wire
furniture that you could you said it
hurt we were like i can't even
relax on this and when i sit
on this i'm looking at the main
house and i'm wondering what the fuck
is going on in there
share with those creeps with soames and
they're looking at me assume you know
presumably um so we then decided we
have to get the fuck out of
there we had brought our bags in
but then because we were like let's
just do it and then were like
no let's get outta here what are
we doing i'm going to do this
and so i like you know message
the guy and i was like i
felt really dirty it's not private and
you know
pictures are misleading and kinda get my
money back i still had to pay
for the cleaning which i was like
oh nah that's ridiculous i was in
and out was so rude but i
was just like whatever get me out
of here and we drove home aware
like whatever to get me out of
here exactly we got home we were
like oh i love my ha we
haven't got anywhere for me
months and months of months and then
i live just to be back everyone
it it is as frank sinatra said
so nice to go traveling but it's
so so much nicer to be home
but you make good so you could
just like i don't like you bringing
that comedy bang bang's yeah um but
you could just go to a place
not pay for it say it's dirty
and then come back home you get
the same field
thing and it's just like travelled some
wow yeah it was like traveling i
was like so much stress like it
was pointless
yeah that sucked now you know i
think i've told you i went to
new zealand and i visited hubbardton oh
you did i don't know if i
know this man shot on the show
i went down to ah australia new
zealand with the thrilling adventure hour this
was twenty fifteen
sixteen something like that wow wait no
it couldn't have been twenty sixteen cars
in twenty sixteen we went to australia
we don't then it wasn't so camber
well i'm just saying there have been
a lot of going there for you
alright lauren you've proved your point
you're right oh i never i never
met zona
i've had a look that's about that
little little little
it was so we went to the
whole group of us went to hobbiton
which is set up so nicely like
it's say they kept the sets from
the movie the exterior sets when they
shot there and so you can't let
go in the hobbit houses but you
walk around like the hobbit neighborhood and
it's really cool that at the end
at the end of the trip there's
an in
where you can like have you can
have lunch you kind of drinks you
know and it's it's done it's done
perfectly i have to say that's clearly
yeah it really is you do really
feel like you're you're in that place
and it's really charming nice things and
and stuff that feels like you would
be in the movie or is it
exactly and getting yeah okay yeah yeah
it's like just like pizza it's like
shepherd's pie and things like that and
you know ale and shit and yeah
yeah it's really great yeah cool it's
really nice i recommend it if you're
ever going there that's cool i'd like
to go to new zealand someday it's
beautiful i would like to go back
for sure
scott you haven't been there now i
was invited ah the new prime minister
to do yeah know i was invited
to go do a podcast with one
of my favorite musicians who's from there
and we were all setting it up
and then it turned out he was
like ah the day that i was
supposed to do everything was was
thanksgiving and i was like could we
do this another day but it's not
a holiday there so they were just
like it's just another thursday over there
so you didn't go because you don't
want to miss thanksgiving ah sor yeah
it's in terms of our holiday roundup
yeah i find this surprising because i
feel like you were all about canceling
every holiday i want to cancel
every holiday my sweat myers found dozens
yeah there's family the pool of the
family is so strong yeah can i
guess who the musician was yeah is
it okay to say it was neil
finn yeah yeah yeah we're gonna do
like some sort of audio like fake
biography of him with
like people like jermaine playing characters and
stuff clement from fighting you are gonna
fly to new zealand yeah they're gonna
fly me to new zealand and i
was gonna watch like they're the the
big i think it was a crowded
house reunion show that they were there
wow or something like that and and
it just the timing just couldn't work
out but ah they have a new
record out ever
one should check it out it's very
good
wow it's called we hate thanksgiving crowded
house's new record yes they do just
came out i really only know one
song
duda duda
yeah that's only in general or by
crowded house um don't miss
oh yeah now hey oh when the
way oh yeah alright let's take a
break okay mine
and we're back we're back we're back
we're back we're back we're back where
back or backward backward back by baba
baba baba baba bow bow bow bow
bow bow bow bow bow bow bow
bow bow bow bubba bubba little tummy
remember the legions commercial wow
okay well it went a little something
like this zakho like when your mind
goes like when you're having fun but
wait if i'm doing right up sir
but when your movie doesn't ability that
it'll return to the theory that the
bible is a whole thing
it was a commercial for lw for
ninety two you'll find them all amortized
them lots of stuff enough to make
you sick sago like when your mind
goes like what you've had enough of
doing grown-up stuff so when your lady
you to do your job reba mobile
the mobile way it was for adults
like no it was for kids watch
but
but what kids are doing adults grownup
stuff you know like your chores i
think the looney tunes should change their
name because that's it's not cool to
say someone's insane anymore so you know
to call can you say they're loony
no that's even worse alouds calling someone
in saying yeah alright switch jays they
should just be the fun guys the
animal show
yo
the animal and a two human show
who are the two humans elmer yosemite
sam and elmer fudd oh the eighty
from sylvester not to shift some of
them some people who are just feel
like um yeah sweet checks true the
three human are mostly animals show there
are people who are just feet what
we don't talk about them
having it in the muppet babies well
thinking tom and jerry without not learning
tunes yeah sounds i think there were
a couple you know what one they're
one of my favorite looney tunes of
all time features a lady that's just
some legs is the bulldog who reluctantly
makes friends with the kitten yeah oh
yeah climbs on his back and he
needs
his back and everything yeah many in
the receipt books that shaped cookies that
he thinks the ah bake in the
oven and he cries it's adorable kids
one of the cutest cartoons ever and
the next build name's larkin anthony
after this funny yeah but speaking of
ah weird things happening to pets like
when we were away the other week
molly suddenly was out in the front
yard and no one knew how she
got out there it was just marking
out by the front door like wow
let me in she was she wanting
to come back yeah no one really
heard it and then
georgia went over to the door and
was like looking at the door and
looking back at all of us like
hey aren't you going to get a
letter if it was so oh that's
really funny
no flames again anyway i went all
around the front yard looking for any
kind of entrance and the only one
was the front door yes so someone
had let her out or she got
out of the front door her so
maybe she learned how to open a
door i don't know like the well
i don't think someone let her out
of the front door that's because at
that point you're just saying it's polar
janie it was me
no cool i'm saying i wouldn't let
her out know it was me i
did it on purpose i feel like
i will be a fun story i
feel like this is what happened i
feel like at some point cool op
or or i but i don't remember
doing it but i guess she doesn't
either ah let them out to go
potty and then left one of them
out there which has had
opened a few times so do you
say like potty you like to be
animals yeah i don't want i don't
want them to think i'm crass or
for them to pick up foul language
yeah sure only your dog's going around
knowing the word shit when you're walking
the dog okay take a shit take
a shake a utah ya
hey there yes good shit good i
just take i take oh
go go go nobody thinks hey joe
she goes like hey lie there yo
series they're all like code words don't
tinkle potty my little sweetie chums
you're the type who would say that
why are you making fun of it
no no i can tinkle i'm not
that type take it back lauren you
are no we don't ever say that
you just did say it but i
said as a joke no i'm going
to ask mike
and what wins when you want michael
ask him right now when you want
to go because war ever say tinkle
i go mikey take a little dougie
the toy toy
yes ma'am
i'm doing it i'm doing it lady
yes my queen sick ah sick are
you texting mike is that what you're
doing paul yeah we we expect you
to take up any lapses in conversation
you can text in the middle of
a show i just texted him does
laura never used tinkle for piss yeah
here we go the word tinkle for
pitt
sorry we're doing this not technically zeta
because like water for chocolate i think
of this
i once went to like water for
chocolate ah at the santa maria i've
been a thousand times
and i once went to this movie
i only went once but ah there
was there was someone i went to
school with who happened to be there
at the same showing and she was
really mad because i thought the movie
was so bad and it was i
was laughing for like water for chocolate
yeah i don't know what is that
movie i don't really know what that
is i don't either
you know what i that book was
extremely popular at a time i was
working at a bookstore i was there
i was at a bookstore for bridges
of madison county which whoa fucking loved
and like people would ya be like
hey do you have an ego bridges
yeah it's that's so nice yeah have
i told you this in like a
cool way it's like be working on
a book
store in the nineties when that movie
comes out and everyone wants that book
that's like so like hey i'm the
one who has it what can i
ask you why you think that i
don't know it feels like you're in
an indie like you're yeah you're sure
huh
it's like eat pray love when that
came out like i watched i mentioned
this like months ago but i really
liked this movie was talking
oh yeah yeah yeah but that's like
it feels it's like the nineties this
movie possibly but like it feels like
you're in that
you're like everyone keeps coming in wanting
bridges of madison county are you sure
you want to be being that i
know exactly what you mean and what's
funny is it doesn't feel good
ah so it feels good from my
perspective because i'm like because because when
i was in at that point in
time i wanted to be an adult
who worked in a bookstore doing middle
so that so but you were like
i hate this yeah this is like
it's a trope of the funny supporting
character who's like works in a bookstore
and you're always like what a cool
life and they're always like bored and
disaffected yes and you go wow how
cool would that be but no it
sucks is what paul went when bridges
of madison county came out and i
was working in that bookstore that was
a true low point in my life
where i'm highly glorifying it and you're
like the saddest time in my entire
life i had had to mute hit
rock bottom
just about i mean i had to
move back in with my parents i
was broke um this way they all
have the best job that i could
find it was it was in my
old neighbourhood like like or a neighborhood
away from my old neighborhood just like
me at the olive guard my dog
my my sister had just gotten divorced
and she had to move
back in home oh my chances with
her two daughters but seeing this is
a movie we were all miserable we
were all ms and tried to get
up like at the crack of dawn
to open the store every day monday
through friday people buying books that early
ah we had to get there at
like i had to get up early
so i could get ready to go
to work and then the store opened
at like eight am was something like
that coffee shop part of it or
no there was there wasn't it was
just my sources but nobody hadn't seen
to do in the ninety s open
at four pm yeah i
i had to wear an apron it
was it was a waldenbooks anywhere wouldn't
get the books tag oh it was
a it was a joy to wear
an apron yeah it was a chain
and oh so dirty that they'll get
your clothes dirty the books are filthy
people don't realize new books because the
ink is dry and so it'll it'll
get all over and or your smear
the book
yeah um but i i did not
there was no one on the staff
that i could really make friends with
you know what i mean well older
or something no no they weren't like
mother pretty much my age but there
was one oh my god there was
this one guy that i sort of
i he was like a real frank
burns type where i i despised somebody
i felt sorry for him huh this
is from mash the brown show yeah
don't watch such a dusty show yeah
it's very dusty very brown
um and i so i hated him
but also felt sorry for him at
the same time and one time i
was i was it was wintertime oh
god this was so bleak i got
there the sidewalks are covered with ice
i get there before him like right
before him waiting for the store to
be opened um and i watch him
walk up the street
eat and he slips on the ice
and takes such a hard fall it
was like that that philip seymour hoffman
pratfall in ah ah along came polly
it was hard and i had to
turn away because
because this guy was such a dick
to me but he was also like
he was such a door i felt
bad for why was he a dick
to you though was was it because
he didn't think you were as smart
as him or just i'm sure that's
true but he also felt like i
wasn't i wasn't as gung-ho an employee
um and i think
he he could tell that i did
not take it as seriously as he
did and he always liked to tell
me what i was doing wrong or
what i could be doing better and
it was like what could you be
doing better in a bookstore you sit
there by the register and you'd bring
up books well if you're lucky you
do that but if you're not you're
out on the floor and you have
to reorganize things you have to fuckin
dust you have to do you know
all the all the
just like the busy work of of
retail what you have to do when
you reorganize books like put him back
in alphabetical order or what what more
you have to put them you have
to put them back where they're supposed
to be because people don't do that
um thanks all over the store you
have to straighten things yes yeah setup
yeah yeah and there's like if there's
magazines
and newspapers you have to make sure
those are nice and tidy and all
that shit i feel like i just
busywork it's because i feel like that
sounds not horrible as far as like
retail like i like streaming in books
it cause it's kind of have you
ever had any job though they're all
terrible know all jobs are terrible i'm
sure i would have wanted to quit
instantly but i'm thinking about when i
i like that's why that's why it
was a babysitter scott because i didn't
like being i didn't like being on
the floor you know i didn't like
that kind of acts you don't like
until you've never worked any retail is
no i worked at one restaurant one
one navy pier job
and then i was wonder what what
when i worked on navy pier as
a color for the boat coming you
answer right that's right i was so
here sucking but i get on about
my second grade teacher works at barnes
noble in the summers and she has
always done that she still does and
i always and
i always loved her and she always
wore like sweat pants and sweat shirts
and i loved hugging her she was
so soft yeah her name was rocky
balboa
should have been up and down the
steps she was rewarding before school soft
little lady cyan lady song little late
and i see her in the summer
at the mall and um sure you
always like hi mrs whatever your name
yes and i still love if i
saw her now sure but she um
she always made that seem so nice
you know because it's like but i
mean what it really is is that
teachers aren't paid enough and she has
to get a job in the summer
exactly it's like that's not fair but
when i think about that i'm like
oh it seems kind of pleasant like
if you like books and knew you
know i don't know but i'm sure
it sucks it's not the thing is
like the the job itself of course
is not difficult and it's not
not it's not taxing it's the it's
the it can be the people that
you work with and the customers yeah
yeah oh my god there's this guy
on tiktok who does these really funny
videos about beauty pie
god i wish i had his name
but he does these videos of he's
a comedian and he does like sort
of talkback videos about working at ikea
and has gotta say something yeah thank
you dig it i guess i'm pronouncing
his last name correctly but yeah he's
hilarious i thought he was from philly
at first because he's he's from baltimore
and the accents are very similar his
videos and video have so so much
it's all just about like fuck
if the customer it's so funny it's
it's like it's a it's a weird
it's a it's a stupid thing that
a customer will say and i've heard
all of them and then he responds
to each of them the way you
wish you could yeah well what a
customer in a bookstore say that would
be annoying
they went well it's like if they
would ask for a certain book and
then they would get indignant if you
didn't have it or if it wasn't
out yet or whatever who people asking
to use the bathroom people saying i
this is cheaper somewhere else like he
covers literally every this scott covers every
single thing that people say that's just
like reit's really funny yeah but it
is crazy to think about people coming
up and being rude i i need
him i see people being rude in
a store i feel horrible i once
had a lady an old older white
lady try to return a choice sure
i'll tell you why in a second
you fucking idiot
well laura never did i told you
so you could imagine his little self
yes and i did i wanted you
to see him young white guy missing
two front teeth it's the same guy
so this this older white lady comes
up to the counter and says i
want to return this book because i
didn't realize that the people in it
were black oh she's buying it for
and then like she i think i
must have had like either a reactor
there was like a moment of silence
and she said that's terrible isn't it
it's like yeah it is and you
also don't have to tell me this
reason i could just yeah exactly you
could say i bought the wrong book
or some yeah that is so for
us as you remember it was called
the black family roots by lexical roots
it was a children's book and it
was like it
black family doing whatever happens in a
children's book like a picture in a
journal anyway that's terrible we'd need to
take a break and we'll be right
back
and we're back and it is time
for a three-tier you've got ma there
yes would you like to tell them
what the three-tier is i would i'm
actually very curious to hear what it
is to i never heard of a
three dry glue that yield
this is called last letter
called last letter and gonna miss this
so much so much when i laugh
anymore yeah yeah
this is very important it's submitted by
law submitted by will this is okay
thanks will by sheer force of will
um we do an improv scene and
the last letter of of whatever the
previous person says must be the first
letter of the next person that's fun
whatever they say
and you can't use abbreviations what does
that mean oh meaning like i guess
you can't say asap or something like
that like e g i
yeah sick
um i mean abbreviations in general you
can use in the middle of a
sentence i would i can't anyway whatever
i want yeah will can't stop me
yeah we'll take a break for a
second we're gonna we got this okay
we're very low in me yeah don't
worry about well oh i want you
to take a nap honey should should
we go to bed
should we go clockwise so we know
it's you know what i mean fare
well are are our screens the same
because it didn't we figure out that
they are in your um weaker neurons
you're on top i'm to the i'm
climate top boss at the bottom
so i have scott top left me
top right paul bottom okay do mind
that's what i have lauren i have
scott top left lauren top-right me yeah
she got a not hide yourself because
we can't move the video so we're
gonna see your face for a second
i can move it you can't move
it joshua i can deter okay so
who's it it's me first then lower
and then paul yeah
likewise okay josh get out of here
we did it
okay so ready are we gonna start
or the lawnmowers loud enough yes start
your mueller
right here we go
hey ding-dong
wassup wassup know it's going to be
a g i said i said gsa
i just ah say gw us up
players okay let me ah let me
try again let me say again ah
um
oh it's ding dong i saw was
that players simply wonderful to see you
underneath the bed i have a surprise
for ding-dong
gugu gaga i hope it's something fun
like a magazine
entertaining for sure you'll see
entertainment weekly in fact
tut tut looks like raise tons
yeah no the sun is shining as
you can see plainly
you know the sun is shining why
are you lying to us right now
well i have something i want to
confess i've been lying because i am
trying out a new technology where i
am on
i am wearing a lie detector test
and it is trying to see if
it knows if it's lying and by
it i mean me
and let me understand this you're wearing
a lie detector test then you call
it new technology
you see i am being arrested
and they need to test my lies
but so i'm lying on purpose to
see if it can tell if i'm
lying when i am lying or if
i'm not lying when i'm not lying
good god that sounds like um ms
ding dong and i don't know what
to tell you other than you are
in trouble for
real look all i have to say
ding dong is we brought you here
because it's an intervention
no not again so we there's nothing
fun under your bed
damn i hate to tell you this
but no
whoa boy this is really hard to
say but no there's nothing under the
bed
darn it i really was looking forward
to whatever that was gonna be i
thought maybe it could be first magazine
like i said then i thought maybe
maybe some candy like sour patch kids
or i don't know if something really
cool like your old baseball uniform
man that does sound nice but unfortunately
there's nothing under there and underwear
that didn't work i know i was
i just wanted to make myself say
underwear and
dammit paul stopped for a second alright
i need to tell ding dong why
this is an intervention look ding dong
we're tired of you coming over to
our house every day and not ringing
the bell and we wanted to ring
the bell
let me get this straight so you
are tired of me coming over every
day and not ringing the bell but
you liked that i come over every
day you just want me to ring
the bell so if i were to
come over and go ding dong that
would be good
definitely better but i wouldn't say good
necessarily you see a big part of
the problem is is we also don't
like you coming over every day
yeah you don't
tell you the truth no
okay this is also difficult to say
but we don't want to be your
friend anymore ding-dong we're tired of you
coming up we're tired of your catchphrase
what's up players we just don't you
know it's it's it's not working between
us
something's been on my mind that i
wanted to get off my chest too
i can tell that you guys have
something going on here something a little
deeper than what we have all three
of us together and i want you
to see once and for all admitted
you sleep in that top bunk and
you sleep in that bottom bunk and
it's much more than just that you're
not just roommates you're not just friends
you're married
to
to to ting die how did you
how did you guess yes we are
in a committed marital relationship
perhaps you're not comfortable with that i
i've always felt like you didn't want
to be our friend because of that
to tell you the truth it's more
that i just felt left out and
i always thought we were just a
three group of friends but it turns
out it's a two marriage and a
one friend and that's a third wheel
lolly gagging around like this we should
have been more careful scott
time has taught me that
you know friends will be friends forever
but marriages can end and i want
to end this marriage paul
lookie here my dream is coming true
except i'm not too happy about this
because i don't want to be divorced
it's shameful wow
i do i always get help um
let's see ah i don't think there's
any shame in being divorced i think
it's just when a man doesn't love
a man anymore we should just end
this relationship right here and i get
half your money and you'll have to
be cool with that
tone wary
when to worry
notary and i can help you with
your divorce papers
shit but what about the bible i
believe it and everything that it says
seriously even all that stuff about ah
that guy jesus
stuff about that guy jesus i've heard
of that guy
yes you have he's my best friend
sorry scott and ding-dong at the same
time
excellent we can talk about jesus now
and we can let ding-dong know everything
about him and maybe ding-dong will accept
him into his heart
that would be pretty cool actually kind
of know jesus already he cared be
on a beach one time
every time i've read that poem i
imagined it was you ding dong
great i'm i thought that you were
imagining it was me this is another
reason why we shouldn't be married
don't fight so much just don't be
married
duh
he already said he wants a divorce
accept
now i don't and i want things
going to also be married to us
sweet giblets i'd love that
then it's decided we're all going to
be married together me scott ding dong
and me
a e i o said old macdonald
when something similar happened to him and
this is great so e io
okay i feel like you need to
get your brain checked
ditto
oh i oh i e is what
he said backwards one time when something
similar happens goodbye i'm off to get
my brain checked
debt feels like the end
definitely
oh my yay wow was a good
fun game it wasn't a game i
don't see reacher certainly it was a
three-tier that's true not all features are
games but all games are three x
true monopoly three so noisy creature soccer
three or ah hunting man the most
dangerous game three
darkhorse three
what is that story they were like
it's time for three-term i'm going you
have a ten second headstart ten seconds
that's not yep that's right hopefully longer
was like twenty four hours at least
i think so something like that yeah
right where are those real sometimes yeah
okay well thank you everybody for listening
we're at threesome usa on twitter and
instagram three team usa at gmail dot
com if you wanna send us a
three-tier um and we thank you for
listening and we love you very much
shh yay see you later bye bye-bye
uh